all right yeah we have the first trailer
for glass and I have to say I think it
looks pretty awesome this was given to
us today at Comic Con so here before we
get started be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you can stay up to date on
everything that is happening at San
Diego comic-con so to start off if you
are not familiar with a glass it's a
different type of superhero movie and
it's the third movie in a three movie
saga the first movie was unbreakable and
it came out in the year 2000 the next
movie was split which came out in the
year 2016 and glass is the third
installation tying them all together
glass is about three main characters
David Dunn who's played by Bruce Willis
Elijah price or glass who was played by
samuel l.jackson and kevin crumb or
beast who is played by James McAvoy so
in the beginning of the trailer we are
introduced to dr. staple who says she is
a psychiatrist but she's a very specific
type of psychiatrist she says that she
specializes in individuals who believe
they are superheroes so here's what you
need to know in the first movie
unbreakable we are introduced to Elijah
Pryce aka mr. glass
what do we call you sir first name mr.
lastname class as he mentions in the
trailer his bones are super fragile and
they break super easily hence the name
mr. glass he was bullied a lot as a
child because of his frailty my bones
break easily
and I've had 94 breaks my wife but you
have an extraordinary thank you so his
mom bought him a bunch of comic books so
he could get confidence from reading
superhero stories as he grew up he
started to think that these superheroes
were actually based on real people their
stories were just over exaggerated while
he searches for his purpose in life he
comes up with a theory based on the
comic books that he's read that if he
represents extreme human frailty there
must be someone unbreakable at the
opposite extreme he then starts his
quest throughout life to find this mr.
unbreakable inter David Dunne who is
also searching for his purpose in life
David was riding a train that derails
and crashes killing a hundred and thirty
one passengers in which he is the only
survivor and had no injuries
Elijah realizes that this could be mr.
unbreakable it could be the person that
some of these superheroes are modeled
after so he leaves his card on David
Dunn's car David eventually goes to
Elijah's comic book store that he owns
this is where Elijah tells him his
theory and then becomes his mentor
helping him understand his powers he
discovers that he has superhuman
strength and that he has extrasensory
perception that enables him to glimpse
criminal acts committed by people who
make contact with him
you think you have superpowers it's a
feeling I have to touch them you believe
you are a protector basically if he
touches you he can kind of take a
glimpse into what you've done he also
discovers that he has a weakness
just like Superman's weakness as
kryptonite his weakness is water after a
few heroic acts throughout the movie and
saving two kids at the end
Elijah throws him a celebration and at
the end he extends his hand for him to
shake this allows David Dunn to take a
look into his mind and finds out that
he's actually a super villain he finds
out that he has caused over hundreds
deaths including several terrorist
disasters and the D railing of David's
train Elijah insists that the deaths are
justified because he was looking for him
the whole entire time and that his
purpose in life is to be the villain to
his superhero the movie ends with Elijah
calling himself mr. glass and then David
eventually turns him in in which Elijah
is convicted so that's what you need to
know about Elijah price and David Dunn
in the movie unbreakable split
introduced us to Kevin Crum it's a man
who has 23 different personalities
inside of him the 24th personality that
we find out is called the beast and the
Beast has superhuman abilities I have no
question there are two dozen identities
that live in that body with you the
Beast it's common any minute now for you
guys but what I am questioning is your
belief that you are something more than
human and yet it is true
Kevin crumb ends up kidnapping three
teenage girls in which he ends up
killing two the third one shoots him in
the chest twice but it seems to have
zero effect but she does end up escaping
at the end of the movie it goes to a
diner in which the news is on TV and
several people are watching it the news
is doing a story on Kevin and his 24
personalities in the situation that
happened one of the females notes a
similarity between Kevin and a
wheelchair using criminal who was
incarcerated 15 years earlier as she
tries to remember the nickname he was
given the man sitting next to her tells
her that it was mr. glass and who was it
sitting next to her that told her that
none other than David Dunn from
unbreakable
so glass is the movie that brings all
these three characters together David
Dunn is pursuing Krum superhuman figure
the beast in a series of escalating
encounters while at the same time glass
emerges as an Orchestrator who holds
secrets critical to both of them so
glass is really about Elijah price aka
mr. glass and the Beast teaming up
together as super villains going against
the superhero David Dunn who is
unbreakable as mr. glass says in the
trailer a lot of people are going to die
are you ready
a lot of people are going to die I don't
do this are you ready glass will be
about David Dunn trying to stop mr.
glass and the beast from killing many
many people that sounds like the bad
guys teaming up so there's everything
that you need to know about this trailer
and the back story that they talk about
in the trailer as well how do you think
it looks and how do you feel about the
third and final installation of this
saga let me know your thoughts feelings
hopes and dreams in the comments below
be sure to like the video and subscribe
to my channel so you can stay up to date
on glass and everything happening at San
Diego comic-con thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
you